- Mike vit dans la rue depuis
un an.
- Je me suis ramassé dans
la rue. Des erreurs de parcours,
puis le temps de la Covid
n'a pas aidé non plus.
Au deuxième confinement,
là je me suis planté comme
il faut. Je me suis ramassé
dans les ressources icitte
à longueuil.
- Nous sommes devant le revant e
de l'église Notre-Dame-de-Graces
à Longueuil. Une vingtaine de
personne en situation
d'itinérance espèrent obtenir
un lit pour la nuit qui vi
- La gang qu'on est icitte
ce soir. Je vais me risquer,
mais le quart ou la moitié
n'auront probablement pas de
place pour dormir ce soir.
homme qui refuse d'être
identifié attend lui aussi
une place pour la nuit.
- Je suis tombé malade en 2018,
puis j'avais un commerce
avec des employés. Du jour
au lendemain, ma femme est
partie avec un autre quand
j'ai su que j'avais un cancer;
puis du jour au lendemain,
tu as beau essayé, essayé,
mais la médication coûte
tellement chère. Puis,
je me suis ramassé à la rue.
- Selon la Table en itinérance
de la Rive Sud, il y avait
environ 70 itinérants àLongueui.
Ce nombre a maintenant doublé.
GILLES BEAUREGARD, coordonnateur
table itinérance - Rive sud
- Il s'est installé des nouveaux
services, d'hébergement
d'urgence à Longueuil.
Un organisme qui s'appelle
te du coin qui s'est
développé pendant le temps de
la covid. On avait planifié
25 places, puis c'est dans
une église. Au jour un,
une dizaine de personnes et
après quelques jours c'était
rempli à pleine capacité à 25.
Et depuis ce temps-là,
ça n'a pas laché
- Plusieurs candidats et
candidates dans la campagne
électorale municipale à
Longueuil ont suggéré
des propositions pour venir
en aide à ces personnes.
Mais du coté dess
communautaires, la confiance
n'y est pas.
- Un coup qu'ils sont élus,
bien, on passe à l'action là.
Fait que c'est ça qui nous
inquiète après, parce qu'un
des enjeux qu'on a du coté
de toutes les re
c'est la cohabitation avec
la population en général.- À Laé
mobile vient d'être mise
en service pour les itinérants
parce que là aussi le nombre
de personnes en situation
d'itinérance a presque dou
MATHIEU FRAPPIER, coordo. Réseau
organismes, intervenants, Laval
- Les gens nous arrivent avec
des problèmes plus lourds,
plus complexes et qui demandent
des solutions beaucoup
plus globales. Boom est arrivé
la pandémie qui a hautement
fragilisé les personnes et
nos services bien sûr,
et on a vu une augmentation
du nombre de personnes,
qui devenaient visibles.- Et co,
les organismes en itinérance
souhaitent des engagements
fermes de la part des candidats
et candidates. rencontré les prs
formations politiques qui ont
pris des engagements plus
ou moins solides, selon
les candidats et candidates;
mais on observe une véritable
préoccupation.
- Mais que ce soit à Laval
ou à Longueuil, les besoins
en itinérance sont
de plus en plus grands.
- Il n'y a pas assez
de ressources. Oublie ça,
les ressources, tu cours après.
Tu comprends... si je regarde
je vais te dire une affaire...
ns, ils pens, ils pens, ils penn
fouiller dans les poubelles.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, à Laval